we're talking about multiple injured
receivers in Cincinnati with the Giants
Chris Simms my goodness holy cow who
who's left to play are they gonna bring
back David Tyree that's a play receiver
is Victor Cruz available but you've got
Golden Tate who suspended four games for
violating the PE D policy he claims that
he took a substance in connection with
fertility treatment that he didn't
realize was a banned substance once he
realized that he stopped taking it but
it wasn't in time to avoid a positive
test Corey Coleman suffered a torn ACL
that's a reclamation project in New York
that they had some hope for sterling
Shepard has a broken thumb this this is
like the the the curse of the Bambino
applied to the Giants when they decide
to trade away Odell Beckham jr. because
they can't find a healthy receiver now
or somebody who will be available from
week one because Tate they're their star
free agent acquisition is gonna be gone
if he loses his appeal for the first
four games yeah well I think the first
thing I thought of her and this whole
situation was up man Eli Manning he's
got to be sitting there going gosh I
mean okay we get rid of Odell Beckham
jr. we're looking positive things are
looking good we got a new vibe here and
now he's going who-who am I gonna throw
to or man I'm gonna have to give the
ball to say Quan Barkley in the run game
a whole lot and then that's the first
thing that I think jumps out to me just
like we said with the bangles and AJ
Green now it's just gonna put more
pressure on sacrum Barkley the run game
of Pat Shermer and all of that that's
what scares me about this ultimately now
I think sterling Shepherd with the with
a hurt thumb I mean I expect him to see
week one certainly Corey Coleman see you
later Golden Tate Mike this is an
interesting one don't you think I mean
again you know me I am so anti PE d but
he's put himself on a limb here to where
I want to go okay if he's saying what
he's well you know if what he's saying
is true then there should be the proper
paperwork here and we'll the NFL have
like the common decency if he's saying
what he is saying is actually true to
say okay well you're trying to get
pregnant I mean this is a different one
for me here I don't know how I doesn't
matter it doesn't
doesn't matte look because here's what
you here's how it works right if if you
want to pursue an exemption yeah for
legitimate legitimate medical purposes
for something that's on the banned
substances list you submit a therapeutic
use exemption in advance you don't start
taking the substance have it dawn on you
a few days later that it's it's can it's
something that's on the banned
substances list and then say oh oh oh
God does it say there's a lot of
questions raised by golden tape agreed
the statement and the problem is the NFL
is never going to answer those questions
the NFL's not gonna fill those gaps I'm
curious about the timeline like how does
this happen
that you start taking this substance you
realize within a couple of days that
it's on the banned substances list but
somehow in the interim you're randomly
tested you test positive like either
that is horrible luck or maybe he took
it for more than a few days or holes in
this story and the reason and this isn't
anything against Golden Tate Chris the
problem is every guy who ever test
positive has an excuse like this there's
always you know Taylor on last week we
saw his very emotional statement about
how he unknowingly took a banned
substance nobody who test positive ever
says you got me I was trying to cheat
and I didn't try hard enough to cheat
because I didn't cover my tracks I
tested positive and I'm busted oh well
yeah but nobody no nobody does that but
these are different you know this is
different than oh I took adderall by
accident or did something like that hey
Julian Edelman didn't even make that
excuse he just said I don't know what
happened right so that's where I just
again I'm with you with the questions a
golden tape certainly a shaky thing but
I would think that at very least and my
understanding was it that he got on this
this you know fertility drug right and
then was just randomly drug tested and
then he realized oh no I've taken this
so I'm with you it's suspect I'm
certainly throwing the challenge flag
I'd like Ron Rivera
I'll remove Iran excuse me from Rivera
out River Run to to review this
certainly but if the paperwork is there
to say that he was legitimately trying
to do it you don't think the NFL will
have any heart here and oh no you don't
okay alright so now look the appeal is
now
resolved by independent arbitrators but
bottom line is it's a strict liability
policy responsible for what's in your
body period and you if you start making
exceptions based upon guys who have the
avenues available to get a therapeutic
use exemption and don't do it that's the
message here don't ingest anything that
you don't know is not on the banned
substances list if there's any doubt get
yourself the appropriate paperwork in
place in advance and then once
everything's cleared up you can take
what you need to take but but for all
the other players out there just ask the
questions get the paperwork talk to the
Union talk to your agents before you
start ingesting anything if you have any
doubt whatsoever that it may be on the
banned substance
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports